Good morning Hank; it's Monday.
Nerdfighters often ask us if we're religious,
a topic we've been reluctant to discuss over
the years mostly because the quality of discourse
about religion on the internet is...atrocious.
That said, many nerdfighters know that a decade
ago I worked as a Chaplin at a children's
hospital. And I was also briefly enrolled
in, although I actually never attended, the
University of Chicago's divinity school. So
today I'm going to share everything I have
to say about religion. Hopefully that will
lead to a productive and thoughtful conversation,
although given the history of the internet
and conversations about religion...probably
not.
Okay Hank, so I would submit that almost all
human lives are usually lived in a state of,
like, functional nihilism. Very few of us
believe that human life is devoid of all meaning
and that all we should do is answer to our
base urges and fulfill our basic desires and
try to distract ourselves from pain or fear
or unpleasantness, but almost all of us act
as if we believe that. Like I have this massive
parallel processing unit that sits on top
of my neck that I could use to, like, contribute
to cancer research or write a novel or puzzle
through quantum mechanics. And I have this
amazing body that I could use to plant trees
or fight wild fires or harvest food for the
poor.
Hank, remember that time I said I have an
amazing body? I don't mean that I have an
amazing body. I mean everybody has... it's
amazing what our bodies can do.
But I don't usually do any of that stuff.
Hank, most of my free time is spent, like,
watching television, playing video games,
or searching for lols.
Christians, Muslims, atheists, whatever, all
of us share this worldview; almost none of
us would abandon our comforts to help others;
almost all of us would acknowledge that much
of our time each day is wasted.
In short, Hank, if we just judge humans by
their actions, we look like a bunch of nihilists.
But we aren't nihilists because we all feel
called to make the world better. To understand
and observe the universe. To make art, to
bring beautiful things into life. To contribute
in some way to the human experiment.
Everybody wants their lives to matter, to
have meant something. That call to meaning
is the foundation of religious worldviews,
but it's also the foundation of successful
secular worldviews which is why I don't really
care to debate the existence of God with people.
Like, Hank, imagine you wake up in the middle
of the night and your house is covered in
smoke and you hear an invisible voice shout
"Your house is on fire!” Hank, in that situation
I would find it, like, totally uninteresting
to have a discussion about where that voice
was coming from and how it got in the house
and was it God or a fireman. I would just,
you know, leave.
In short, Hank, for me at least, debating
the mere existence of God is a way of avoiding
the deeper and more devastating question of
how we are going to bring meaning to human
life.
I think that's, broadly speaking, the point
of religion. Religion is essentially a response
to revelation. And that revelation almost
always calls us to embrace meaning, or, if
it doesn't innately exist, then to create
meaning. But that's also true for atheistic
humanism. We are all facing the same question:
what are we going to do with our consciousness?
Will we seek to fight poverty or climate change
or disease or war or spend all our resources
ensuring that we have a beautifully manicured
lawn with absolutely no weeds?
Sorry, I'm on a bit of a lawn kick at the
moment because my next door neighbor is not
terribly happy with me for leaving the country
for two months during the, uh, lawn growing
season. It's just grass, dude! Actually...
it's not just grass. That's his problem. It's
also a lot of dandelions.
So what are we going to do about consciousness
and how are we going to balance our urge to
be more than nihilists with our need to blunt
the sharp edges of consciousness with funny
stuff like Paula Deen riding Paula Deen riding
me or Humpy Hank?
Those are interesting questions, Hank, and
Nerdfighteria has been talking about those
questions for years now. Some of us through
a religious lens, some of us through a secular
lens, but the lens doesn't interest me as
much as the questions.
Sorry this video didn't contain many jokes.
To make up for it, here is a baby rhinoceros.
Also, as penance, I will eat 36 disgusting
sandwiches on Friday.
Hank, don't forget to be awesome. I will see
you on Wednesday.